a Harvard professor representing Harvey
Weinstein is out as a faculty Dean did
you hear about the law professor who
just lost a job for daring to be a
lawyer for an accused sexual harasser
Sullivan was also verbally abused and
the residents where he lives with his
family was vandalized
Ronald Sullivan and his wife have been
Dean's at this Harvard dorm for years
but now some students say as a survivor
of sexual assault I don't feel safe in
winthrop house this campaign by a group
called our Harvard can do better
worked eats a little bit must step down
Harvard removed Sullivan and his wife
from the residence hall they feel unsafe
they said they're lying they're lying
Alan Dershowitz taught law at Harvard
for decades anybody who says they feel
unsafe in the presence of a lawyer and
his wife are looking you in the eye and
committing the equivalent of perjury
they don't feel unsafe they've learned
the language of the new McCarthyism the
mantra of the day is we feel safe well
that's just too bad
learn to deal with it you're gonna have
to live in the real world in which your
neighbors your friends your relatives
are gonna disagree with you and if you
start using the criteria of unsafe in
your life you're gonna be a failure more
important I don't care if you're a
failure you're going to impose
restrictions on the rest of us these are
mostly young women some have been raped
assaulted isn't it reasonable that they
don't want to face that again no it's
not reasonable not to want to face the
reality that due process requires that
everybody be represented so you can get
fired from his professor job don't the
students have a right to say look we're
living with this guy he creeps us out
because of what he does get somebody
else well if they could say that then
they could say it about somebody who
supports Donald Trump for president
somebody who is a Muslim somebody who's
gay somebody who's Jewish you name it we
need to educate our students that free
speech is for
everybody do processes for everybody
Dershowitz has represented pated people
I was the lawyer of last resort if you
couldn't get another lawyer you came to
me Sullivan too often represents people
accused of murder and even terrorism in
order for the rights of all of us the
rights of the guilty and the innocent
alike to be protected we have to live in
a system where we vigorously vigorously
defend the guilty you get the right to
counsel no matter how despicable you are
thought to be and how horrible the crime
you're accused of you get due process
Weinstein has lots of lawyers Sullivan
didn't have to volunteer to do this when
you're a tenured professor I think you
have a special obligation to take the
most controversial cases because law
firms often won't take cases like that
these students would have fired John
Adams they would have not allowed him to
come to the Constitutional Convention or
write the Declaration of Independence
because he had defended the people who
were accused of the Boston Massacre the
Boston Massacre helped start the
American Revolution Bostonians threw
snowballs and rocks at British soldiers
the soldiers then fired into the crowd
his cousin Sam Adams was furious at him
he wasn't a true revolutionary Adams
opposed the British and yet he thought
the right to represent somebody
transcends any of these other
ideological or political issues later in
life Adams wrote that his defense of the
British soldiers was one of the best
pieces of service I ever rendered
judgment of death would have been as
foul a stain as the execution of witches
this should have been an educational
moment instead the administrator just
removed Sullivan he failed that
educational moment instead of teaching
the students he acted impulsively at
their demand and he let the inmates run
the asylum almost all the administrators
cave if you don't cave you won't be an
administrator you
then your decisions have created a
harmful situation among harvest student
body but especially for about Harvard's
black community Dean Sullivan is black
but black students attacked him to these
712 means to my face that I should view
his representation of Harvey Weinstein
as a good thing because of that
representation will trickle down to me
and other black men like me can
constantly face an unjust justice system
to that I say that their speeches cited
an ever growing list of aggrieved groups
ensure the safety and well-being of all
students and workers in their houses
including survivors transgender and
gender non-conforming people it's like
an Olympics of oppression everybody
wants to claim the mantle of
victimization the more victimized you
are the higher your status and prestige
and the more you can claim that you're
part of the oppressed group rather than
the oppressor you win the oppression
Olympics you have to call yourself a
victim today to feel welcome at many
universities the protesters strongest
point is that the Residence Hall is an
intimate space where students eat sleep
and study shouldn't they get the Dean
they want at the marginal revolution
blog Tyler Cowen writes
Harvard's right it's about helping
students focus on their studies removing
distractions I couldn't see their point
these people live together I don't see
their point at all you'll live in a
world where there are gonna be many
distractions you're not gonna live in a
world where you can determine everything
according to your own view if you want
to do that you know move to China or
Iran I want to go to American University
you have to learn how to deal with
distractions